what I have to do to collaborate with
you what is the odd it's the ultimate
goal that I must complete you got to
survive a tough mudder survive utama not
talk about yeah and I might be able to
collab wit she's got nothing to do with
it but it's got everything to do with
that wanna see okay it's not not about
information or Ella told me about scale
okay you'll be fine right but thanks man
appreciate
hey guys i'm ryan right i just got back
from seattle Warner Brothers pictures
apparently came across the channel and
they asked me if I wanted to do tough
mudder in case you guys don't know what
that is that's a ten and a half mile 10
and a half mile obstacle course with
some of the most insane obstacles ever
so many times I thought I was gonna die
so it kind of made sense why they want
to bring me out there to help promote
the edge of tomorrow blu-ray release
which is right here Oh BAM that's right
I got it on blu-ray mother [ __ ] it is
an awesome movie it is one of my
favorite movies of the year possibly my
favorite movie of the year and I'm not
just saying that's kiss Warner Brothers
ass although Warner Brothers if you're
watching huh this nose looks a little
bit Brown today I'll do anything for you
guys doing a didn't seen obstacle course
they call it tough mudder and there are
times you're literally climbing
mountains a mud it's just nuts and then
they had weird obstacle courses you know
like summer like some you've seen before
like jump from here to there jump over
this giant [ __ ] wall I was able to do
that was able to pull myself up over a
wall this fat ass was able to do that I
had some great guys on the team with me
I found out about this like a month and
a half before but I didn't look into
what Tough Mudder was and some of those
obstacle courses involve you having to
like crawl under barbed wires and then
you have to go through a tunnel and you
pull yourself there's muddy ask Tom only
you fall into a bunch of mud water line
you have to jump into a huge tank of ice
water it's literally filled with ice
that way they're like we're not [ __ ]
around you jump in it you got to go
under this thing and then you got to
come out on the other end to climb your
way out of there I don't even get the
point of that I threw up somewhere
between six to nine times let's put it
like this they had a medical center
there after the race was done the
medical center had to fill me with two
IVs and you know what something got me
thinking and this was a genuine thought
that ran through my head Tom Cruise must
be super athletic
these 50 you're watching movies like
edge of tomorrow and you're like holy
[ __ ] this guy's incredible I want to
talk about it after the video i want to
show you guys some footage of the events
of it's a vlog some of the Warner
Brothers put together at a great [ __ ]
time out there doing Tough Mudder and
after the video I'll tell you about my
experience and who I became after this
battlefield hey guys ryan right here i'm
currently in seattle washington or
seattle I don't know states that well
Warner Brothers semi had you tomorrow
blu-ray release promotion they want me
to do tough mudder right now I'm going
to go meet all the [ __ ] people that
are going to be a part of this gonna
have dinner with them I'm nervous I get
nervous around strangers I tend to make
dick jokes when I'm uncomfortable which
just makes everything more uncomfortable
but let's try to bond so I just met my
teeth that's great I'll just met my team
wait who's on my team mystery ok cool
cool so Susan ok ok lower lower
you wrote on two olympic teams I'm just
the best in the world everything else
hey i am going to disappoint the hell
out of these guys Michelle yeah okay so
I've run in rockland what the why they
might mean this is so no not everyone's
gonna be like a lazy pense person like
this really sucks what's your name sir
james mcgrath James that's loose we got
two piece does it do and how are you if
I did for this I i do Ninja Warrior you
do need your warrior yeah what's real
what am i doing all you guys do Ninja
Warrior work okay okay okay there's none
other than schmoes know over here this
is amazing holy crap and you said you
see my channel which is so flattering
big fan of the channel I'll tell you
what's amazing is that I actually
completed the tough mudder today for
edge of tomorrow you're gonna be doing
it to market to tomorrow yeah how was it
dude a piece of cake wasn't really like
no I here's what i have i have some
cross-country training um a tough mudder
is kind of like cross country with a lot
of crap in between there's scrabble I'm
crap to go under clamp it off ramp
there's an Arctic tank at one point
that's really gonna make you lose your
manhood for but no it's a great time
you're gonna have a blast just be
friends with the team and if you got
some American ninja warriors on your
team
wow dude it's a real honor to meet you I
like AG I'll start with once I finally
realized who you were likewise my friend
ya know 12 the ways to follow his
channel they haven't bought our channel
yet no you gotta clean up a lot better
this is me after a month every time
people see my channel they always say
schmoes know and jeremyjahns so this is
like a not a complete honor to finally
meet you hey well I can Roman you got
the batman shirt I got the Super Mario
Empire Strikes Back no we know how to
dress okay perfect well thanks man
appreciate it good luck you survive
tomorrow come on the show I totally well
I'm so nervous right these are big
tymers at WB
I picture my blog real fast you I yeah I
put you in my blog real fast okay I need
you to just answer me one question this
is Tina she's been in contact with me
for this why did you invite me when I'm
clearly one of the most out-of-shape
people here cause you're a legend that's
why I'm to skew video killed it for
warming up on that damn oh you saw that
that's great that's fantastic Chloe we
added right you everyone your soap up in
the muscular I'm like there's Olympic
athletes here well thanks wait to make
an ass out of myself thank you this is
sean nodes up another athlete that I am
NOT well the thing is though like I I've
done tough mudder before grab nah I'm
not like Ninja Warrior tough like these
you so okay I'm kind of nervous too is
like I hope I'm not the most like out of
shape one there and I'm pretty sure I'm
the most out of shape one day it's about
endurance a lot of it too ok so just
takes a lot of mental strength yeah okay
something i don't really possess that's
another gonna have to do fake an injury
and go hey i'm gonna fake it right
before it starts yeah oh this is Alyssa
she's the one who contacted me um I
asked Tina this question no why'd you
invite me when I'm clearly really out of
shape because you really really love our
movie and that's the really it's that
simple to get invited to this no just
got to like the film alive no because
you're great personality and you're
gonna add a lot to detain my hammock
okay i'll just share people on that
sounds more like my style i did it today
you get it to that sure did the whole 10
miles oh my god yeah did this sounds
insane well thank you alyssa see me this
is a oh my god he just forgot it was
gonna light a spark from the next
restless road trip um oops turn a pecan
I'm so sorry rus-rus yes so how'd you
get invited to this are you part WBA IM
not good people from the WB invited me
or they want to kill me I don't know
that's more like what I'm thinking hey
your pointer yeah I probably worked out
twice before this event so
I used to work for a show on the WB so
maybe this is their get back at me and
that's Eliot yeah Elliot back there
how'd you get invited to this I want to
they invited me to a couple posts on it
and everything wait a second way to see
I've noticed there's a lot of movie
review now did you guys give bad reviews
for tomorrow it's literally my favorite
movie okay and I said that in my room
they want to kill you yeah I've been a
big supporter of Tom Cruise's come back
for a long time yeah come back he never
left he kind of left a little tiny bit
then he it goes protocol and then he was
back on top again okay no I followed his
career for a long time yeah but you just
say you did so last year mm right in the
world's toughest mudder which is the 24
hour race so you basically do the Tough
Mudder as many times in a row as you can
and so you can't go anymore what hour
did you get to I made it to 19 I was
screaming I want to fight you I want to
see if I could stand we're having a
Poussin person did you not gonna be
running in pooper driving poop my kind
of conversation right now big for dining
here we're gonna get pizza the day
before voice-off mutter we're okay
Johnny and Amanda hi I you know
ridiculously good-looking co haha this
is cheeseburgers
your aprons up waterboxx am I know
notary not it over here i have a married
yet but I hear he has a YouTube channel
to a fitness on Howard's fitness Scott
Harmon fit I've heard of you recognize
oh god how'd you guys get invited in
this just through American enjoy and
American Olympics the Olympics I feel
like I should really know who you guys
are and I'm a total how many a
subscriber's do fine I finished channel
it was 600 is like 12,000 that is so
puny compared it was like a new be
sealed 30,000 over here six every well
style some 10 Wow no seriously you guys
are like both really good-looking it
happened she should be together cuz here
looks yeah I don't care about your
personality yes strictly your looks yeah
that's all you guys really need I
overheard that you person we're gonna
pursue modeling how did you know you
were so good looking you can do that you
know I mean one day I was just like wow
I'm really really been looking i had the
same thought but don't want to leave to
me it's pretty of these you are looking
at you look in the spoon that's what the
trick is so i got about two hours of
sleep [ __ ] tired should have
masturbated I'm glad warner brothers
gave me this opportunity but I'm
immediately regretting this decision we
just got here
these are okay I watched rising that's
real last name wiggling hey it's real
last name that is I've heard of it all
you've heard it all what what have you
heard I've heard it today I prove to
people that I'm a man even though I only
have one testicle yeah athlete semi-pro
football player semi pro ball player
Olympic gold on Utley with two gold
medals or two gold medals and we're on
the same team I'm gonna use it I owe you
an athlete yeah you're an athlete ap
happily like that the caps oh yeah to
sit tissy I think when I want this is a
cameraman Chandler yeah looking forward
to worry about man today is gonna be
good it's gonna be exciting so Chandler
do you have any friends look it's jesus
jesus i bet you never heard that Lord
aveva never got that a classic as it
Rachel and Monica oh yes he's continuing
yeah usually somebody's excited we're
sticking together look look at look at
us now is so fun look at this heart
tattoo yeah we'll talk about that which
she got this drunk one day I woke up
with it I really did have you may know
her yeah no one else would get 730 know
you can see the real tattoo inside of
the heart they promised me Tom Cruise
will be here yeah you didn't see him I
did not see Tom Cruise said oh is that
him that's my god that's yours yeah mine
is so much bigger than yours it's way
bigger damn dude like can't believe
yourself they're so fun yeah
Oh
we're about to begin you guys I kind of
hate myself right now
nine times I vomit I'm doing great
so yeah tough mudder was an interesting
experience something a lot people might
not know about me and you probably don't
doesn't come across in these videos I do
something called personal development I
do a lot of that you know some people
call like self-help books some people
call motivational CDs but I do listen to
a lot of that I've read a lot of that I
and like I'm one of those people who
like I'm always saying quotes I worked
on training my mind and heart to become
Who I am today and for some reason all I
translate as is a horny douchebag damn
like this was like to help design by
reigns you know just doing one mile I
was like holy [ __ ] I just go a mile some
of these obstacle courses and stuff you
look at them you're like there's not a
chance in how I could do that if there's
more we have to go down this she really
steep hill and you have to use a rope to
come down whatever it is I don't want to
think about her ass but literally you
have to like push yourself to the limit
you don't realize what you're capable of
doing until you actually do it that's
how it is for me and a lot of things I
am constantly encouraging people to
start their own YouTube channels I'm the
last guy to be like now this is my thing
you do your own thing I love helping out
people with starting up YouTube channels
I know we're not like the biggest
channel and planning but still it's like
I'm so happy to see that this channel is
growing like every day we jump up like
two to three hundred new fans a day
which is huge that is insane numbers to
me I remember we were jumping up like
five people the day now what's that in
the hundreds and I'm like nuts yeah I'm
having a great time doing it honestly
like if you ask me like 23 years ago if
I was capable of doing this I would I
said yeah but I wouldn't have truly have
the belief in myself and it's like one
thing that a businessman is a
businessman who taught me this he said
there's two types of people average and
successful average people are gonna give
you advice on how to be successful but
the people you should listen to you are
the successful ones on how to become
successful it just makes sense now I
know I'm not like super successful or
something but for what the channel has
become this is the first time in my life
where I feel like I am successful it's
something and that's really thanks to
you guys like big time I feel like I'm
about to cry and I have cried too many
times on this channel so give me a
second I'm not crying but
tough mudder you know it just goes back
to like everything like the one thing
that I heard is like success is like
working out like you start off with five
push-ups you do five push-ups and then
eventually you graduate to 10 then you
graduate to 15 it sounds cheesy as [ __ ]
the reason why i said average and
successful is because there's average
people will hear quotes and then they'll
go that's so cheesy that's so cliche but
who are the ones that live by these
cheesy cliche quotes successful people
and so it really does come back to like
mentality and attitude towards things
like you really do have to endure
persevere find more strength in yourself
like it is it was crazy like I came out
feeling like a brand new confident human
being actually no I was pretty sick
later on that night I felt like whoa I
didn't realize what I was capable of
doing sometimes when you just throw
yourself in there you gotta do it and I
was bringing up other people start our
YouTube channels because I read all the
comments now I'm gonna be honest I
haven't been the best at replying back
to comments because I like to go in
order when they came in and there's just
more and more every day now that I don't
want to skip anyone I read these
comments and I and I went a few times I
do get to interact I see that a lot of
you guys are like more knowledgeable
than I am when it comes to this stuff
and so I'm you guys write long ass
paragraphs and of your opinion and
everything and it's like do if you just
stay true to yourself and you just be
that person mmm so many of you like
subscribers could totally have your own
channels one day and then we could
totally collab wit should be so [ __ ]
awesome Taylor's Houston for example you
set faster off like jiggly jelly like
you just some names off the top of my
head like you guys could have your own
channels and I strongly encourage it but
I'm not sure which one of you guys it
was but I remember talking to one of you
and you're like no I can't do it and I'm
like dude seriously like I don't know
why this is around my wrist if you
really want to do it you you can totally
do it you never know what you're capable
of doing unless you try like it's just
that simple like don't let fear talk you
out of something you don't need some
type of really solid thing yet just go
out there and test
waters use it as a playground at first
and just have fun and then you guys are
on YouTube all the time you might as
well join the behind the camera stuff or
in front of the camera stuff whatever
i'm trying to sound cool you guys not
just you three but a bunch more of you
literally could start up your own
channels and be way more intelligent
than i have it does take like belief in
yourself to do something like Tough
Mudder it does take something like of
going I'm not gonna quit I kept quoting
Rocky I was like I just want to go the
distance I just want to go the distance
I don't care about how fast it is I am
or how slow I am I just I want to go the
distance it took six hours and yeah I
wish I went a loaf aster but still and
like the camaraderie of these guys Scott
Herman fitness dear he was like a great
[ __ ] leader out there man like if
there was one guy who is really just
like was really helping to motivate me
it was that dude Zack something sorry
dude you were [ __ ] like awesome too
man the girls were all great can't
remember any of their names now because
i'm sexist now i just can't remember any
of the names all of them were just
fantastic man Russ dude Russ and uh oh
my god I spent most of the obstacle
course with this guy and I don't
remember his name right now the black
guy not the black guy I mean there's
another black guy he has a vlog channel
but the other black guy whatever he was
like a bigger example of me than
anything else because like he he said to
me at one point he knows he's the
biggest guy on the team and he knows
he's not the most fit for this but he
just went the [ __ ] distance man and
it really is just about a hanging in
there like seriously since tough mudder
I've been thinking this way like again
any enemy I already thought this way but
it's been like super amplified and I
just want to share it and warner
brothers they were so [ __ ] kind I was
kind of surprised I'm like you guys are
treating me like I'm just a friend that
is so cool he doesn't feel like some
business meeting the whole time like
you're actually just a hanging out with
these guys and they're all [ __ ]
awesome Lissa and Tina and all my god
why eyes are horrible with names look
then then like other Warner Brothers
people
it really was one hell of an experience
like I could see how this links the edge
of tomorrow with all the beach for
fighting sequences the [ __ ] weight of
the world they have to carry in those
armored suits yeah it makes you feel
like a badass by the time you're done
while you're doing it you feel like a
badass like when you're getting through
it you're like I am a badass I could be
in the edge of tomorrow sequel thanks
for watching this video you can go out
there you can buy edge of tomorrow on
blu-ray favorite movie of the year not
just saying that the brown nose but if
it's helping out Warner Brothers I will
gladly say it again and again this is
ryan right take care now bye bye
you